last wednesday twitch suffered the
biggest hack in its history its entire
source code got leaked as well as
details of a secret project that
amazon's been working on and a list of
alleged earnings for twitch's top
streamers dating back to 2019. that's
right we now have a much better idea of
how much twitch's top dogs are actually
pulling in the leak also contained what
appears to be a list of twitch's do not
ban streamers it's crazy the whole thing
is crazy but what's even crazier is that
the person who leaked this says that all
of this is only part one
[Music]
all right then the only people in the
world who don't like big leagues are
companies governments and boat captains
so unless you're one of them i suggest
you subscribe to the score esports and
that way you'll never miss a video just
like this one
do it
come on
do it
on monday last week twitch joined in
with the rest of the world and mimi on
facebook being down for most of the day
but if we made a list of tweets taken
moments before disasters
this would definitely be up there oh
yeah big time so the twitch thing was
leaked
we now know how much every single
streamer has made on twitch.tv in the
past 26 months a little over two years
then we're gonna play a little game
of higher lower
where we are going to check which
streamer has made more money and is thus
a more valuable human
bigger number better person of course is
the name of the game this is made by
automated shout outs to auto as always
on wednesday october 6th a 4chan user
shared a link to a 125 gigabyte torrent
which they described as an extremely
poggers leak involving twitch now they
claim to contain the entirety of
twitch's source code going back to its
origin a list of every property owned by
twitch as well as details of an
unreleased steam competitor from amazon
game studios called vapor all of that
sounds juicy of course but what really
made everyone lose their [ __ ] was this
they also claimed the torrent contained
creative payout reports from 2019 up to
the present and encouraged people to
find out how much money their favorite
streamer is making twitter user know
something was one of the first to trawl
through the files to find details of
twitch streamer payouts they first show
twitch payouts for the month of
september 2021 and we can see big names
on there such as shroud hassan ludwig
mizkiff amaranth asthman gold i mean the
list just goes on pause if you want to
take a closer look honestly i think
we've covered just about half the people
here on don't at me the even juicier
numbers came next though with a list of
the top 100 highest paid twitch
streamers from august 2019 until october
2021 the top 80 streamers were all paid
over a million dollars by twitch and the
numbers get quite eye-watering near the
top we've got tim the tatman making 3.2
million over the past two years same
with ludwig over 5 million for nick
marks summit 1g just below 6 million xqc
with a whopping 8.4 million and critical
role almost making 10 million dollars
over this period now we're not going to
go through every name here of course but
basically if they're big on twitch
they're on this list and there's no
nothing pointed out in a final tweet
this is just a fraction of what
streamers actually earn when you take
into account things like donations and
sponsorships which can be of course
incredibly lucrative so what exactly are
we looking at when we see these figures
well it's difficult to know where
exactly every dollar comes from but it's
safe to say it's within the twitch
ecosystem we know that for every
subscription twitch splits the revenue
with the streamer for some streamers
this revenue along with donations is the
vast majority of their income but for
the faces that dominate twitch they
could also be pulling in a lot more from
outside sponsorship sources this is
something that moist critical who
appeared at number 22 on the list
himself was very explicit about in his
video on the leak the numbers that were
released in the leak yesterday are wrong
they're too low the streamers on that
list every single one of them well at
least for like the top 100 are making
significantly more than is represented
on those leaks those leaks only cover
subs and ads they are not covering the
donations through stream labs because
that doesn't go through twitch so they
wouldn't have access to those numbers
and they're also not counting sponsors
and they're also not counting twitch
contracts a lot of the top 50 streamers
on there have contracts with twitch
which add a significant chunk of money
to streamers income within a few hours
of the leak twitch tweeted out
confirming that a breach had taken place
and they were working to understand the
extent of it later that night an
advisory on twitch's blog explained that
the data was exposed due to an error in
a twitch server configuration that
allowed the hacker to access it they
added that their investigation is still
ongoing to understand the impact in
detail and that they have no indication
that login credentials of twitch users
have been compromised but i mean if you
haven't changed your password already
maybe do that now you might think that
twitch streamers would be mortified that
at least part of their income is now
known to the public but for the most
part
they seem to find it funny at least on
the surface but i i kept scrolling down
i was like i don't gotta worry
my name is not gonna be on here
obviously hey i don't make enough hey
you guys know how stream it is and then
i see this bro how sad is it
that the hacker that whoever hacked it
photoshopped me in this as well to make
it look like i'm making money at all
working the hardest job on the planet
dude they don't want a brother to
succeed i swear to god so this is
obviously fake news obviously this is
fake news a lot of big names on twitch
started to jokingly refer to each other
on twitter by the number they appeared
on the list it was all fun and games and
they didn't seem to be annoyed that a
lapse by twitch had ended up with part
of their income being leaked as miss
39
i just want to say melania if you're
watching this
i'm number 39
and wealth
myth and nate
sub 100 and
they're accumulatively poor
so if you really want to take it to the
next level
perhaps the most ridiculous thing that
i've seen from all of this has to be
that someone made an extension for
twitch that shows every streamer's rank
on the list next to their name
oh cool i got rainbow look at that
how do you get that otto
that's a fire extension the thing is
we all know that the top twitch
streamers made bank it was probably the
worst kept secret on the internet that
the big names are loaded despite this
some people have called out the big
streamers for not being transparent
about how well-off they are this was
something that moist critical was quick
to clap back on people were getting mad
at me like oh so charlie it turns out
you make money on twitch you're ranked
22 in the world on twitch in terms of
earning how [ __ ] disgusting how could
you mislead us charlie and i just don't
get it because i'm not misleading anyone
just because i'm not some douchebag who
flexes their wealth all the time doesn't
mean that i don't have money i know i
dress like a cartoon character and all
that but it doesn't mean that i am not
well off i'm extremely lucky and
fortunate to be in the position that i'm
in and i make that very clear all the
time for a streamer like saikuno though
who came in at number 28 on the list
he's been pretty shocked by some of the
backlash basically what happened for me
was someone took a like a out of date
clip out of context and tried to make it
like i was saying i was poor or
something
when literally five seconds before the
clip they cut i said i'm not poor and i
can afford most things i want and then
for some reason they left that part out
because literally like five seconds not
maybe not exactly five but you know what
literally right before i said i'm not
poor i'm doing fine um and here's what i
really think guys people are like cycuno
says he can't pay his water bill to get
subs and i'm like look guys you must
think i have the nicest landlord on the
planet if i never pay my water bill and
they haven't kicked me out yet now it's
important to remember here that the
numbers and names we're seeing represent
the absolute cream of the crop on twitch
most streamers can only dream of making
even a fraction of these amounts as tech
and commentator rip pointed out the leak
covers the top 10 000 streams on twitch
according to google's data twitch has a
total of 9.2 million active streamers
which means this leak accounts for just
0.1 percent of the total streamers
reddit user the ultra sheep lord put
together a graph demonstrating the
streamers revenue compared to their rank
and added that according to the data the
top 10 percent of streamers in the top
10 000 make almost half of the total
revenue on twitch so that means that the
other 90 of twitch streamers are making
the other half of the revenue the point
here is don't drop out of school or walk
out of your job today to become a twitch
streamer because of this leak on twitter
streamer alinity said the leak should be
proof that people shouldn't become a
streamer for the money as very few
people make it a few days after all this
a reddit user posted another part of the
leak to asthma gold subreddit now this
time it had nothing to do with how much
twitch streamers were earning it
appeared to be a list of streamers and
reasons to not ban them some of the
reasons look like attempts to catch
mistaken bands before they happen
usually to do with a streamer's name but
right there we can also see big names
like ricegum and tyler1 with a message
telling the reader to not suspend them
and to escalate any violations to what
are presumably a pair of higher-ups at
twitch another strange part of this past
week which may or may not be related to
the leak are the jeff bezos faces that
have been popping up all over twitch
users reported that the headers of games
on twitch had been replaced with a very
zoomed in image of jeff bezos the
billionaire founder of amazon which
twitch is owned by now although this
didn't last long it was pretty bizarre
to see and could have something to do
with twitch's source code being leaked
as well as everything else we've talked
about it really was quite weird the top
is jeff bezos over here
is that jeff bezos
all that aside it's time for our next
question now why did this happen
obviously hackers like to hack it's kind
of their thing but what was the intent
behind this well taking a look at the
original 4chan post again we can see
that the user referred to twitch's
community
as a disgusting toxic cesspool and that
their aim with the leak was to generate
disruption for twitch and create more
competition for them they then sign off
the post with the hashtag do better
twitch now you may recognize this slogan
as one that came to prominence in
september 2021 as part of a twitch
boycott by streamers who felt the twitch
wasn't doing enough to crack down on the
growing number of hate raids on the
platform these kind of hate raids are
automated by bots and targeted at
marginalized streamers or streamers of
color to spam their chat with verbal
abuse and slurs twitch's total watch
time on the day of the boycott took a
not insignificant 16 hit now twitch did
recently announce changes to address
this including giving streamers the
ability to request phone or email
verification from any viewer before
using their chat which also sued two
organizers behind some of the most
egregious hate raids but for the hacker
responsible for this recent leak it
looks like twitch isn't doing enough at
least for them now this also comes at a
time when twitch is going through what
many people are calling an exodus of top
tier talon as many big names leave the
platform for youtube in what is becoming
an all-out contract war between the two
giants they recently lost the likes of
tim the tapman and dr looper but did
manage to keep nick mercs on the
platform so for twitch this has been a
rough week in what's already been a
pretty rough year and remember this is
only part one the person who posted this
leak to 4chan told everyone that all of
this is just part one of what is to come
there's also going to be a part two
maybe even a part three who knows how
much data they've actually got their
hands on and most importantly what kind
of information could be leaked in the
not too distant future
i'm sweating
okay
i'm sweating and it's i'm in the first
[ __ ] paragraph is it the hat maybe
i'm sweating because of the hair as well
as details of a secret project amazon's
been working on and also a sentence that
i've said eight times but can't remember
i think you should have some stuff from
my intro
if not i'm gonna do this